[Musique]
alors que les prix augmentent forcément
notre pouvoir d'achat diminue on va
profiter mais on partira moins longtemps
c'est pour ça qu'avant de partir en
vacances on cherche tous à dénicher les
meilleurs plans pour l'été location à
petit prix volent pas cher bon plan
comment faire le maximum d'économie sans
se faire arnaquer attention tout d'abord
aux annoncements sont gères une villa
vue mer à 100 euros la semaine ça
n'existe pas et faites attention aux
conditions générales de vente en tout
petit parce que souvent les sites ont
tendance à se protéger beaucoup tout
comme les vols locaux ce qui vous attire
souvent avec des prix d'appel battant
toute concurrence mais en fonction de
leur de départ du nombre de bagages ou
de votre place dans l'avion le prix des
options peut parfois se révéler
gigantesque prendre l'avion cet été sera
pas toujours une partie de plaisir enfin
attention aux arnaques touristiques que
ce soit pour les visites les transports
ou les produits dit du terroir pas
toujours authentique ce soir notre
expert Bernard sabbat nous met en garde
sur toutes les arnaques à éviter pour
passer un bel été
Bernard ça va bonsoir un ami la famille
des PNP évidemment président de yaticus
et consultant en voyage alors là c'est
vrai que là on est à la réponse à
quelques jours quelques semaines de
partir en vacances et on est un peu
stressé déjà il y a le covid qui arrange
pas les choses il paraît que ça va bien
se passer pour le covid donc on évacue
ouais on peut dire que pour l'instant
voilà ça va bien se passer mais par
contre je suis un conseil comme à donner
à tous vos têtes et spectateurs même
dans le cadre de cette émission il faut
prendre des assurances parce que
malheureusement ça se passe peut-être
bien il faut donc penser à les reprendre
et je pense que c'est très important je
pense que ça il faut le dire et et ne
pas hésiter et ne pas penser parce qu'on
paye avec sa carte de crédit qu'on va
être couvert dans ce cadre là
aujourd'hui il est l'assurance
spécifique covid entre guillemets qui
vous couvre et qui vous permettent
d'être remboursé de la totalité des
voyages et ça je pense que c'est quelque
chose qu'on doit faire et c'est une
démarche qu'on doit faire en agence de
voyage aller sur place et dire voilà
j'avais réservé il semblerait qu'il y
ait une recrudescence je veux me couvrir
vendez-moi une assurance voyage certains
vous disent vous avez la carte de crédit
vérifier ça non ça suffit pas
aujourd'hui établir ces assurances sont
essentielles et la raison parce que
s'arrête l'état d'urgence sanitaire ça
veut dire que tout ce qui permettait
d'être couvert va être annulé donc oui
alors c'est quoi les tendances de cet
été pour les vacances alors globalement
les Français 56 % des Français repartent
en France alors ils sont habitués dans
le cas du covid et ça c'est plutôt
rassurant et on a trois régions qui
explosent
Benjamin c'est ça c'est important de le
dire c'est que évidemment l'Occitanie la
région PACA et la région en
nouvelle-aquitaine c'est un carton plein
aujourd'hui les les on va dire les
campings dans ce qu'on appelle le
tourisme de plein air aujourd'hui c'est
124% de d'augmentation par rapport à
2019 j'étais une année de référence
alors comme il y a un problème de
pouvoir d'achat forcément on se tourne
vers ce qui est un peu moins cher et
plus voilà oui je pense que là aussi on
a beaucoup de d'apriori quand on voit
évidemment la série sur TF1 ou quand on
voit bah le camping tel qu'on
l'imaginait à l'époque on se dit bah ça
y est on est on est plus que de partir
en camping c'est ridicule parce
qu'aujourd'hui quand vous êtes le
camping vous avez des campings cinq
étoiles vous avez par exemple à
Saint-Tropez un camping cinq étoiles
Benjamin il faudra l'occasion vous le
visitiez
[Musique]
oui oui si je passe j'irai voir
exactement
des mobil-hommes qui sont magnifiques et
qui sont extrêmement bien équipés en
encadrement pour les enfants des anciens
géo
c'est des semaines à venir en fonction
mais c'est les semis des semaines à 2000
€ aujourd'hui oui mais quand vous partez
en famille à 6 ou à 7 avec le nombre de
couchages c'est quand même très
intéressant et c'est beaucoup moins
onéreux qu'un séjour classique et
surtout en France les enfants qui font
plus les enfants ça vaut le coup d'aller
en ce moment il fait des décisions les
trois destinations qui sont les les
donc l'Espagne évidemment en numéro 1
comme vous le vouliez ou pas le coût de
la vie est tellement peu cher en Espagne
quand vous êtes capable de manger du
poisson en bord de mer à Marbella et que
vous l'avez pas à Porto Manu évidemment
dans la station de luxe mais vous prenez
un barbier en bord de plage et que vous
payez votre poisson entre 9 et 12 euros
c'est cadeau il faut être honnête que
les extras ne sont pas chers donc c'est
vrai que l'Espagne est en numéro le
Portugal vient évidemment conforter
cette destination qui n'est pas cher du
tout juste un exemple pour le Portugal
vous arrivez à l'aéroport et vous allez
à Lisbonne c'est 3 euros le transfert
entre l'aéroport et le centre-ville en
taxi
non mais sérieux c'est incroyable c'est
une réalité sur les derniers mais la
réalité aujourd'hui c'est que ce n'est
pas cher et qu'il faut le dire et
approcher cette démarche là la notion
d'inflation c'est pas pour autant que
les touristes après il faut être
vigilant et ça vous avez raison parce
que vous avez montré à votre reportage
la notion d'arnaque vous avez toujours
des gens de mauvaise loi qui font un
métier comme les taxis etc et qui
certains font bien leur job et d'autres
le font pas bien et aujourd'hui les VTC
les concurrents les Hubert toutes ces
toutes ces nouveaux modes de transport
aujourd'hui il y a des gens bien il y a
des gens moins bien vous avez des gens
qui vous raccordent à l'aéroport je suis
VTC venez j'ai de la dispo alors qu'il y
a la queue mais aujourd'hui c'est du
grand et n'importe quoi donc il faut
être hyper vigilant alors là c'est le
début des vacances généralement qui dit
vacances de grève
[Musique]
surtout qui check ton bagage
mais mais on le perd en terme de
contrôle et de sécurité ça veut dire
vous êtes capable de rester 3h30 pour
déposer votre veste votre téléphone etc
on devient fou par rapport à cela parce
que il y a un problème de défectif et ça
c'est un vrai souci je vous rappelle
juste un exemple important Ryanair quand
même c'est pas n'importe quelle
compagnie aujourd'hui va annuler au
3e trimestre un tiers de ces vols du
tout simplement au manque de personnel
justement moi j'ai acheté un billet
Ryanair on m'annonce qu'il est annulé
qu'est-ce qui se passe alors s'il est
annulé à plus de 14 jours dans tous les
cas un vous serez remboursé et très
rapidement pas avant comme avant dans 12
mois faut savoir aussi très rapidement
il y a pas de pénalité d'accord si on
vous rembourse si par contre on vous
annule le vol entre le 14e jour et le
septième jour c'est important si on vous
fait arriver dans les quatre heures par
rapport à l'heure prévue initiale
c'est-à-dire si vous deviez partir
arriver à 14h le on va dire le 7 juillet
et que vous arrivez à 18h ça passe ça
passe d'accord si connais pas ces quatre
heures là dans tous les cas on vous doit
une pénalité en l'occurrence elle est de
250 euros quand on fait moins de 1500 km
400 et ça me veut monter jusqu'à 600
euros ça c'est la loi c'est important et
dernière chose si on vous annule le vol
a moins de 7 jours du départ d'accord
vous avez toujours le droit dans
passager d'annuler mais on vous doit des
pénalités si on ne respecte pas les deux
heures par rapport à leur initiale
d'arrivée personne ne le sait personne
ne le dit personne ne l'écrit moi je le
cri au effort c'est important de le dire
parce qu'il faut savoir que les
voyageurs doivent être au courant
aujourd'hui de ces informations là parce
que les compagnies européennes doivent
payer des pénalités que l'Europe a
décidé justement de protéger les
consommateurs voyageurs moi j'ai assisté
une fois à une à des enchères pour
rendre sa place ça existe toujours ça
alors il y a deux méthodologies la
première c'est le chef d'escale je dis
toujours dans les émissions venez tôt à
l'aéroport il faut 3 heures pour passer
la douane déjà
venez tôt à l'aéroport pourquoi parce
que si vous enregistrez vous avez le
chef de d'escale qui va venir vous voir
et vous dire écoutez on
sur internet ils ont payé leur billet
ils arrivent à l'heure à l'aéroport 4h
avant parce que c'est la galère pour
passer un mec lui dit ah bah je suis
désolé on vous débarque plus de place
je vais répondre à ces deux citations
alors expliquez-moi ce qui est important
c'est d'abord on ne veut pas ça après la
douane on vous le fait justement avant
d'enregistre du chargé avant ou après
d'abord on vous laisse on vous fait des
propositions on a l'obligation dans la
législation de vous faire voyager dans
les 24 heures et de vous donner de
l'argent de vous compenser le problème
c'est qu'on ne le dis pas une fois de
plus la plupart des compagnies aériens
disent écoutez ce que je vous propose
c'est je vais vous faire un avoir et
puis comme ça vous partirez vous allez
partir un petit peu plus tard et on va
s'arranger comme ça non il y a des
règles une fois de plus on vous doit de
l'argent quand on vous sur book au même
titre que justement on annule un vol
cette pénalité 250 euros 400 euros 600
euros individu pour toutes les
compagnies européennes qui décollent de
l'Europe
c'est pour ça que je dis souvent que
c'est parfois un avantage parce que
quand on a le temps et qu'on part trois
semaines et qu'on a pas de grandes
obligations et qu'on va Halluin villa et
qu'on se dit j'ai je vais avoir 12
heures de retard je m'en fous et ben si
ça roule on prend une possibilité merci
finalement merci merci
[Applaudissements]
autre autre problème les annonces
actrices alors vous avez vous ouvrez
votre prospectus magnifique une villa
piscine quatre chambres bien placé et en
fait c'est pas du tout ça alors ça c'est
un vrai problème alors ça ça arrive très
souvent alors je vais le différencier si
vous permettez Benjamin d'abord le
problème c'est les annonces sur internet
aujourd'hui il y a des brouteurs à
l'étranger
ça va être des routeurs
ce sont des gens qui sont dans certains
pays qui trichent et qui traînent des
photos qui prennent des photos et qui
mettent une annonce utile ce qu'on
appelle du phishing et il vous faut
réserver ils gardent la compte et vous
vous êtes persuadé d'avoir réservé quand
vous appelez la propriété abîmer ou
plaisantez ou quoi moi j'ai des j'ai
déjà loué ma villa alors c'est pour ça
que c'est important de ne pas choisir
n'importe quel support dans tous les cas
quand on fait une réservation faut bien
vérifier justement si la photo en
faisant un clic droit vous allez voir
déjà c'est la photo existe d'ailleurs
sur un ordinateur vous avez le clic
droit qui permet d'avoir l'adresse IP et
de voir exactement d'où vient la
réservation donc ça c'est la première
indication deuxième indication c'est de
regarder si cette annonce que vous avez
donc eu vous entre les mains elle existe
d'ailleurs ça c'est le deuxième indice
et c'est là avec Julien Courbet vous
savez qu'on règle les matins au
quotidien on voit bien que les gens se
font avoir 40-50 personnes qui ont loué
une même maison alors qu'en fait quand
elle était déjà hébergée chez Abritel
chez Airbnb peu importe ou booking donc
ce qu'il faut citer trois marques donc à
partir de là on se rend compte en fait
c'est une arnaque donc pour éviter ça
choisissez des bonnes maisons sérieuses
qui même en cas de problème aujourd'hui
vos rembourseront une fois qu'on s'est
fait avoir qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
alors justement et vous avez raison
malheureusement rien il y a aucun
recours si ce n'est de faire un procès
contre qui non mais contre qui vous
allez faire un procès la personne
n'existe pas elle a récupéré les acacos
c'est pour ça que je dis aujourd'hui que
les marques sérieuses vous disent la
chose suivante maintenant vous allez
plus payer le propriétaire directement
lorsque vous allez verser un accord vous
allez le verser nous et on est on va
être caution et on va être sûr qu'après
quand vous allez partir justement la
somme a été versée à la à l'acteur du
tourisme parce que si on fait pas ça il
peut arriver ce qui est arrivé à ces
jeunes gens regardez
Julie et Chloé elles avaient réservé en
Croatie une superbe villa regardez
imaginez vous avez réservé ça avec avec
des copains c'est parti pour un séjour
de rêve seulement quand vous arrivez et
ben vous trouvez ça à savoir bah elle
est où la vie là
vous avez payé plus de 6000 € quand même
donc on pouvait s'attendre à quelque
chose de pas mal seulement quand elles
ont contacté le site de réservation bop
ils ont pas été très aidants mais dans
ces cas-là Twitter est là oui
dans ces cas là Twitter est là et quand
on interpelle le célèbre site de
réservation sur le réseau que c'est
partagé plus de 30000 fois avec 18000
commentaires et ben bizarrement il y a
des réactions avec relogements
il faut se tourner vers les sites
labelliser qu'on connaît tous exactement
pas les cités
ils ont pas le choix en terme de risque
c'est énorme en termes de fidélité de
fidélisation pardon c'est énorme aussi
les conséquences que il paye des budgets
importants pour être référencé et le
troisième point qui est essentiel c'est
se dire aujourd'hui en termes de
campagne si on rate cette vente là ça
veut dire que le mec il vient plus sur
votre site et je peux vous dire que
l'effet boomerang quand on a vu là c'est
que ça se démultiplie aujourd'hui au
niveau des réseaux sociaux ça veut dire
qu'on est capable de tuer une marque
donc tout ce qui annonce un peu offside
un site qu'on connaît pas avec une belle
barrage
entre une villa qui est à 3000 et vois
une photo qui lui ressemble qui est dans
le même coin qui était pratiquement la
même adresse et qui est 1000 balles
moins cher c'est qu'il y a une
embrouille il y a pas de secret
aujourd'hui les litiges que nous gérons
avec Julien Courbet tous les matins à
l'antenne c'est ça c'est des gens qui se
disent pas moi je il y avait 1000 balles
d'écart pourquoi j'en profite pas mais
le problème c'est qu'il y a toujours un
look quelque part faut pas se leurrer
dernière question est-ce qu'on peut
est-ce qu'on doit faire confiance aux
compagnie low cost qui passe leur temps
quand même à vivre des moments
difficiles à faire vivre aux clients
difficiles c'est vrai que quand vous
prenez un billet en low cost euh on sait
jamais sur on va partir à l'heure et
surtout si on va arriver alors je
caricature un peu oui mais ça mais c'est
un peu ça vous êtes un tout petit peu
sévère Benjamin je pense que grâce au
compagnie low cost il faut pas faut le
dire honnêtement ils ont pas mis à
beaucoup de gens de voyager ah c'est
quand on voit on a un billet à 60 euros
alors que des grandes compagnies
irrégulières le mettaient à 280 euros
bah ça permet aux gens de voyager après
c'est toujours l'arbitrage classique il
faut choisir des compagnies Low Costes
européennes qui doivent respecter les
droits des passagers et des voyageurs
Air France et Transavia
Iberia c'est bowling
l'Allemagne c'est Lufthansa c'est donc
l'autre
affiliés à une maison une fois de plus
les compagnies aériennes régulières ont
compris quand la France a vu qu'il se
faisait excusez-moi le terme dézinguer
par évidemment les compagnies low cost
et ben ils ont dit on va créer une
filiale on a commencé par hop hop qui
habite été arrêté ils ont pris Transavia
et Transavia marche très fort et très
bien et il y a des prix tout à fait
convenables c'est pas le même service et
après c'est la vente additionnelle qui
fait la différence votre coca vous allez
payer sur place ou un Perrier ou un
Fanta peu importe tout est payant le
bagage et en plus il rentre pas
exactement dans la case on vous facture
19 euros le bagage supplémentaire et
ainsi de suite c'est comme ça
pour
gagner un peu de temps par arrêter
tout est payant si vous allez à
Disneyland Paris aujourd'hui si vous
voulez un face-à-face vous vous pourriez
c'est prestations le Parc Astérix
bien évidemment Bernard ça va merci
infiniment merci à vous